here's a joke by economist mark Perry
what did socialists use before candles
electricity recently celebrity socialist
Alexandria kzo Cortes criticized
ride-sharing apps uber and lyft for
creating financial hardship on cab
drivers it's not untrue these new
services have eased the grip cab
companies have on cities bringing
competition to a brutal monopoly that
never saw it coming the upside for the
consumer more choices better services
and more flexible jobs for people who
can either choose to drive full or
part-time it's turned thousands of folks
into small businessmen for the first
time in years you could actually call
for a ride in New York City but the
downside cab drivers are indeed
suffering but I take this young
socialists more seriously if her
campaign hadn't spent 4 grand on uber
over two months or 2,500 bucks on Juno
another car service
it's the eternal hypocrisy of all
socialists whatever they end up
condemning ultimately is something they
need because socialism doesn't create
anything you can use and when they do
try to create something it always makes
things worse what socialists could do to
New York is what they've already done to
Venezuela Nicaragua and Cuba so you
begin with electricity and trade it in
for a candle that was the joke I got it
I thank you Brian just checking the bank
they're like celebrity vegans who eat
cheeseburgers in the dark blissful that
no one knows their hypocrisy as Greece
dribbles down their chin like Al Gore
flying off to some green conference on a
private jet or people ubering to their
next event while defending yellow cabs
except here we see the lie which is why
after 100 years of soul and bone
crushing socialism smart people refuse
to be taken for a ride so Dana it is a
real problem when there's a dramatic
technological change or innovation
whether it's in the industrial
revolution or the even the agricultural
revolution people get there of
casualties so and it will be more and
there will be more so with auto yeah
we're replacing Fox and Friends both Fox
and Friends hosts will be robots the
first time room here well I wanted me to
break it to you live so you actually
wouldn't make a scene you know when you
fire somebody in a restaurant so they
don't make the scene right yeah you are
being replaced by a robot which
well we won't know since he called her
Lisa paid a job at the FBI gets a job
causes some competition and there is
something kind of cool that the New York
taxicab service figured out and you can
download this app right you can call for
one you can decide if you want to share
one and you could even prepay so that
you know how like annoying when you stop
and you're gonna pay and you can just
zoom out of the car so the free market
product provides for innovation
innovation creates new products that we
want to use that doesn't mean that there
aren't people that are stuck holding the
bill like if you had a medallion that
was worth X and that was worth Y you
based your entire family's life saving
for people who don't a medallion is
almost like a mortgage for your car that
it could be as big as a car house
mortgage like Michael Cohen had and I
thought he was trying to get loans
because they were really powerful this
does remind me of Russell Brand he
lambasted people at a Hugo Boss
reception because he said Hugo Boss made
uniforms for the Nazis and then he left
in his chauffeur driven car there was a
Mercedes and Mercedes actually did
produced Hitler's personal vehicle so
yes this hypocrisy set stuff comes
around I think that innovation actually
is the best thing we can do for it I
think that the training for other jobs
is also important we are living through
a fascinating time we really are even
with kilmeade alive you know a Brian
imagine you know left us hate uber but
if you took is there any way to take
away an innovation I mean imagine if we
said no more 500 channels we're gonna go
back to ABC CBS CBS and NBC it would be
impossible once the thing is here it's
here
well it's right see I'm first off
Russell Brand overrated as an actor and
comedian and he's now on ballers this
year they have taken a turn to surfing
and left football and it bothers me and
I can't believe you didn't work out with
Katy Perry but number two back to your
original question Barack Obama
complained that ATMs took away the job
of tellers you know what now
everything's you got to change personal
responsibility you've got to look ahead
and just
is your job being accessed out you just
told me give me 24 hours no said I'm
gonna be replaced by a robot yes it's up
to me to change I'm not gonna blame the
president if my job gets xed out because
of technology I have to think ahead but
just up to me to get the NIST occupation
to get the next class to be ready for
that necklace but I don't I I mean I
have to I have to say that sometimes it
technology moves faster than humanity
this stuff is going way too quick and
and there's no way to stop it why are
you panicking no I am because I because
I know I will be replaced the five will
be all metal in five years you're
worried you do have concern for people
yeah are facing a possible loss of job
in life by the way Brian I mean what do
you think coal miners are complaining
about you know there's change and then
they say you know what we don't feel
like you know when Hillary Clinton comes
and says we're gonna help you find your
next job you know she's kicking us out
but what I'm glad you say that I think I
get to find that oh they're saying if
you have machines that can do better
than a miner go ahead but don't get rid
of the industry because they found a way
to make it work and there is a market
for it but don't prematurely there is it
because you don't like hang on but
there's not a market in fact the market
in the US has shifted to natural gas and
that's why Ober is succeeding in the
reason why there's such a market for it
is because the city went in and
regulated how many calves
how many medallions they gave out
capping the supply and also there was no
incentive for cab drivers to provide any
good service so that overcomes in now
it's a competitive marketplace that's
going to force cab drivers to innovate
to do better to provide better customer
service so I would say it's regulation
in the first place of why there was ever
a marketplace for a company like uber to
comment well I think the other part of
this is that you could make the argument
that Bill DeBlasio the mayor here is
getting thousand dollars in campaign
donations terminations from a yellow cab
industry so money matters there I think
you can speak for me because that's the
point I was
I thought you release a piece but I but
the other aspect of this and by the way
as a black guy who tries to get cabs I
couldn't be more in touch with what
you're talking about
but I will say that the mayor and others
not only here in Newark but around the
country say you get the streets of this
city flooded with uber cabs it creates
different issues and I think that's part
of the equation in terms of saying we
wanna regulate